yeah this is a devastating incident the  toddler was attacked here in her home in  the black brook area of saint helens  yesterday she was attacked by the family  dog the toddler she was taken to  hospital around 4 00 p.m yesterday where  she sadly died from her injuries now the  police have said that the dog has been  humanely destroyed and they will now  carry out tests to establish the breed  whether it is a legal breed under the  dangerous dogs act they'll also look  into its previous owners and history but  this is a horrific tragedy unimaginable  for the girls immediate family but also  clearly a horrible moment for this  community we've just seen the first  person come to lay flowers outside of  the house and the neighbors are clearly  distressed this morning